[Music]
my brother
so good to see you
sure yeah you've been I'm good how you
doing I'm doing great
looking good good you're looking fit
yeah come on in
first of all I want to thank you for
stopping by while you're in town and
this is a once-in-a-lifetime experience
for anybody to actually have a
one-on-one conversation with you about
the principles and I met you at the
Forbes 100 greatest business minds which
I was you know was just so honored to be
there and I'm thankful that my last name
ends in a C and yours ends in a D
because that's how we met we were right
I was in front of you for we were gonna
go steak to take the big picture and um
and I wanted to ask you a couple of
questions straight from the things I
highlighted in the book first thing was
but what's your definition of radically
open-minded is to simultaneously have an
opinion like like let me give you this
but you think it should go this way yes
and then you say to yourself how do I
know I'm right
maybe that's wrong is that as good as I
can be and then the capacity to hear and
then challenge so somebody comes up to
you with an idea and says okay let's do
this what do you think about that to
harvest the best around you but sorting
it with your own mind so I say to be
open-minded and assertive at the same
time don't give up your assertiveness
but to be curious like am i harvesting
the best because the biggest thing that
most people have their problem is they
get so opinionated that they can't take
in and the worst problem is the worst
tragedy of man kind almost any
individual is that they're attached to
pinions that are wrong and they don't
want to have them stress tested so when
your Oakley open-minded you can say hey
man I really think it should go this way
and then at the same time say to the
smartest people that you know kick the
[ __ ] out of it and tried to say okay now
let's see how the stress tests so that I
can then go to the best or how I harvest
this is gonna be very important for you
to get your leverage okay because you
want to go to this new high level right
and you want to do a lot of things and
in order to do the lot of things you're
gonna have to get the most leverage of
other people but you also want it to be
great blood just like you want it to
because you've got a unique ability with
your taste and everything to be able to
make those choices so you know what's
great and what's not great so in order
to go from that you have to pick the
people who can do that who can deliver
with you what you could do to find
people who are as good or better than
you and then to get that leverage the
key is to try to find out what you're
not good at okay write those things down
that you're not good at and then you get
the people who are good at those things
and then you get the great leverage
right so you know think what are you not
good at and get that great leverage and
then get the sympatico even on the
things you're good at that's great and
as as I'm as I'm building up my leverage
and and and I'm you know building my
team what advice would you give me on
how to find the best in class but the
first thing you need to do for each job
is to have a spec sheets you know the
specifications for that job think about
what are the most essential elements for
each job because each job requires a
different kind of talent okay now just
go ahead is we live in a time where
people know how to give really good
interviews so as I've been building I've
been fooled a couple of times i right
now a very detailed spec sheet they may
say they understand it but then when an
a he had given me the appearance that
that that they
understand the job and they do a stellar
interview but then you know when we with
three months into it into the trench
yeah I don't think yeah here's the deal
what you do is you use the personality
profile testing background checks and
the resume and I do a thing which called
reverse 360 so to find out not just
their resumes but to find out everybody
who knew them in the past and then you
go and do the checking so you have to
start with a spec sheet meaning not just
the skills there were three things that
everybody brings you skills is what
almost everybody hires for it's the
least important of the three things the
most important things are values
abilities and skills so first what are
their values because if you're not
values aligned you're gonna have a
problem like how are you gonna be with
each other the second thing is then
abilities like like some people like you
a very creative thinker somebody may be
very reliable they're not creative the
each person has a natural ability and
abilities that they've gone to develop
those are the things that make you excel
or worse bad at things and then you have
skills and skills is like a you know
okay you can play the piano or you can
sing or you could do that
so each Bert that's learned but if you
start to look at okay what are the
person's values where's that coming from
what were you gonna have Sympatico
because at that deep level you have to
have that simpatico you're on a mission
together it's not just a job right and
then their ability so you got to get the
spec sheet right
once you know the language and you've
got it down then they come and they meet
you and then you you do those kind of
write tests and then you and then view
when when you're starting with them that
the tests don't end okay because you're
you're testing them every single day and
it's how you do that and even being able
to rely on others to even make those
selections for you
you know sometimes because I've done
this
I will look at those particular results
and I can say okay that's that type of
person and as that type of person a good
click with the job I feel like I need a
hard reset I feel like I've been this
computer that's been going and going and
going and going and going nonstop I know
you split things up into personal and
business principles but for somebody
that's coming from a history of success
what advice would you give for that for
me on knowing how it starts to chip away
at your confidence a little bit and and
how you know what steps did you take to
reset and get up out of that and get to
a point where you started to flourish in
life and became like the greatest that
you can be is it just like you know
paying those reflection equals progress
you're you you had the crash you have
the experience that's part of the
self-discovery like what do you want
right now yes you're at a juncture what
really matters to you yes right yes
because you're talking about excellence
yes okay you're talking about keeping
the bar high yes so let's talk about how
you keep the bar high with that
determination and then simultaneously
deal with people who may not have that
bar high because that's what I'm hearing
you yes okay exactly that's that's that
deal okay so now I want to go and
understand and explore that okay how you
keep the bar high and then also get with
them okay cuz you gotta sort them and
some people go on to jump as I something
don't want it but I want to know how you
don't tell you - how are you doing on
that man I'm gonna tell you the truth
like I had to step away from the game
because it it got to a point where where
I didn't
feel like I was playing with players of
my caliber and I felt like I was
investing so much time in the now and in
the the art piece of it that you know
when it came time you know for my
investment in my future as far as is my
business team and the team of executives
around me you know it kind of got away
from me I got to a point where I was
having so much success in so many
different areas and so I wasn't paying
attention to making sure that the that I
was still nurturing the team and then
when I had to come back off a tour and I
had to get back in the business mode you
know I realized that you know I had
outgrew my team wasn't like they were
bad it's just that they weren't at the
level of excellence that I was at that
that level of excellence is very very
hard for me what's interesting to me is
I've seen this happen over and over
again with all different people and I've
we've had conversations with people who
run great sports teams people who run
great teams in any way and have that
element of excellence and and how to do
that so you absolutely you're not gonna
compromise the excellence you shouldn't
yes and so on at the same time like how
do you get the path just find somebody
who's really great at delivering that
and make them a good partner so whether
it's terrors or some buddy there who
says I'm making it my job to deliver
those types of people to you yes yes
okay because you you're not going to do
this the sell yourself wall and you may
not even be the best person to know how
to do it because you gotta get
organizing to the test and you gotta
administer and whatever it is I think
that's what I'm trying to confess is
that
that's that's something I'm not good at
I don't I don't think that you know I'm
good at that I think there's something
you better get liberated once you get it
and once you're doing it it is a kick
because you do because like you say
you're hitting you're stretching up to
that level and then you're if you don't
have great talent around you first of
all it's not a kick it's a pain it's
miserable because then you know you're
just slogging along and what was the
kick the kick the fun or the fun okay
the fun the joy okay it is a blast be
around great people yeah it is a downer
to have people who can't play though
that's what I'm saying - okay so I'm
saying it's a kick like whether if
somebody's my dad was a jazz musician so
I think of jazz you know and I think
like wow great jazz musicians I listen
to great Jeff whoo and I listen to that
and I say wow okay
or a baked great basketball team or any
other group of people to play that
basketball you use that exist example to
play that around is a kick okay and it's
and it drags you down if you can't do
that but in order to do that well
whatever you want in your life you have
to ask who is going to be able to
capable of giving it to me because so
it's an assignment to somebody who is
going to be talented and knows how to
produce and deliver talent like if you
think of it just you're if you're
running a team doesn't mean you're gonna
groan around and do all that talent
finding and talent sorting or whatever
so you're gonna be the captain of the
team and then somebody out there is
gonna say um I know how to Scout I know
how to test I know how to do it you tell
me what who's playing good basketball
with you let me put this one on the
court how do you find him okay no no you
don't like that let me recalibrate cuz
it's my mission the guy next to you is
your talent guy it's my mission to
deliver those stars when you start to
realize that you don't have to do
everything yourself
okay whatever impediments you have you
can get the best talent in the world to
do that with you and it doesn't take any
real time it doesn't cost you hardly
anything relative to the cost of wasting
your time trying to not get those right
people on there
and then you go and you and you refine
the process but don't let yourself be
the guy who's now gonna undertake this
mission and undertake that mission and
undertake that mission okay yes okay yes
you got your talent scout you play okay
that's the definition of a mentor-mentee
relationship I connected with me you
know I have my marching orders I know
what to do with that yeah thank you for
that and then we're gonna and then we're
gonna look yeah okay how you doing it
yeah because I'm saying success is a
five-step process first you have to know
what you're going after your goals then
you encounter your problems
number two you encounter your problems
on the way to your goals then you have
to diagnose those problems and get at
the root causes of those problems and
that might be a weakness that you have
or a weakness that somebody has but you
better get at the root cause and then
once you got the root cause then you can
design something you write down on your
to-do list I got to do this thing that's
number four design and then number five
you got to do it yes you just can't say
okay now I'm gonna do that thing and not
push through the results and if you
could do that over and over that's a
formula for success you only have to do
those five things you got the formula
for success and so but not everybody's
good at all of those steps so it's okay
you don't have to be good at everything
you just have to find the right people
who are good we're not good and then you
go through that last thing in that day
that I wanted to ask you is um who are
some of the leaders that you look up to
and why one guy comes to mind is
Muhammad Yunus Muhammad Yunus is the man
who invented microfinance and is
changing Jeff Canada
Geoff Canada Harlem Children's Zone yes
yeah okay he's a shaper yeah yeah he's a
shaper and he can make it any disruptor
and a disruptor and a smart good yeah
so Jeff Canada is is is one of those and
let me say something else also we're at
a time where is it great to be
successful is it great to be a
millionaire is it great to be a
billionaire yes okay we want to convey
those things to people you can have
character at any level of operating so
the people that I admire the most are
these people who you know they have the
great character and and they're giving
to other people those are the people but
they're so a lot of names come to mind
when you're asking me questions and so
here's the book principles for everyone
that hasn't read the book yet you
explain why you wrote the book and I
think the why is employed you know for
people to know that having read it so
can you explain to me one more time why
you wrote this book and why it's so
important to your legacy I think there
are three phases in one's life the first
phase is you're dependent on others in
your learning then you graduate then you
go in the second phase of your life and
increasingly people are dependent on you
and you're working and you're trying to
be successful I'm in transition from the
end of that phase to the next phase in
my life and the most important thing for
me is to help other people be successful
I learned along the way certain things
that helped me be successful so whatever
success I've had has not been because of
me it's because of principles that I
learn along the way but you know you
have a collection kind of late in life
and you want to pass so I wanted to pass
those along to be able to you know I'm
at the stage in my life
yeah I'm 70 years old yeah I want to
pass along what's been good for me so
that's what I want to do and then when I
do that I can have peace so when I look
at it and and I know like what
the it reverberates not only helping you
because it's such an important thing to
be not only helping you but to help the
others that you're trying to help it
reverberates and I feel good like I will
have done what I did
you should that I have and then I'll
have peace yes
okay that's peace and then I could save
her life yeah play around with my
grandkids and I do all the things that
I'm still excited about so that's why
and that's and that's the most important
part out of all this is to get to that
peace I want to I don't want to make the
most money I want to be known for giving
the most money away I'm known as this
man called Mansa Musa it's a part of our
history he was African King and the
richest man in the world and the the
changes that he made the way he would go
into the communities and in Africa and
and and I'm talking about like the the
way he would just help the underserved
and underprivileged he's a big hero of
mine i'ma send you some information on
man Mansa Musa role models models are
good and I'm very interested but it
becomes the natural arc it's instinctual
that what happens is but like look you
didn't have anything I didn't have
anything and then you go the arc and you
acquire stuff and then okay and then
also people go through
is it status is it proven things and all
of that you get past all that whatever
it is is it the craft and all of that
and then you feel secure and it doesn't
doesn't take much past a certain point
to have more than you feel secure and
then you start to feel empathy you start
to relate you start to see in Justices
you start to see these other things
happen and you can do that and it starts
to bring joy and then you're gonna be
going you're you're gonna be passing
those things and what can you pass and
so it becomes the joys change
from going to nothing to making a lot
and realizing what's it gonna get you
more really and the irony of it is I
never really worked for money
there was an irony that's so crazy I've
never worked for money neither is that
funny thing is for me maybe it's been
the same for you I ended up playing a
game that I liked and got good at and
then they and they gave me money if you
good at the game they give you money
exactly okay that's what it is now I
think that's a very very important part
of people that are successful people
don't realize that most people that are
successful and you know earn a lot of
money they're really just doing their
jobs extremely extremely well and that
is a benefit of it it's just and then it
becomes something that you can use to
help other people because there's but so
much stuff you could buy you know and
then it becomes you know it becomes what
you know it should be used for for us to
to help each other and to and to make
positive changes that's right
so when I look at that and I say okay
now I'm at a let's say you get the money
and whatever comes in and you can get
this thing or you can get a kid through
high school and into a job like your
school yes and then you know what makes
you feel better okay you have to do with
what makes you feel better for me like
and I relate cuz you relate because you
went through it yes and so it's natural
yes it's natural so that our life arc
sometimes we lose sight of that yes
because people are thinking that the
person who's made a lot of money is
trying to make a lot of money or
exploiting Yentl or something rather
than they're just producing things that
people like and the people that are
paying for the things that they like so
that's a good symbiotic relationship
then you take the money and you do good
things with it that's the deal yes yes
definitely I want to thank you for this
vote right here
um as an entrepreneur and I will say to
all entrepreneurs out there that this is
required reading
and you know also thank you for just you
know all the books that that that you've
given me to give to give away to you
know people in the community that may
not be able to afford it and and given
them and it's such a blessing so I I
want everybody to know how pure this
relationship is and you know this this
is the the only ulterior motive that we
have is to empower people through the
information of your journey and all the
things that you've learned which we all
have to go through as being successful
entrepreneurs so it's official right now
principals is required reading if you
are becoming an entrepreneur you're an
entrepreneur doesn't matter if you're 8
to 80 you know it doesn't matter you
could always never too late to start but
you know this is a book that will will
take some years off of your life I feel
as you as an entrepreneur and um you
know it's been something that has come
to me as a blessing because you know
when I read it the first time I was at a
at a certain point of my life but then
at this point where now I'm like my
second mountain and I'm at a point where
where I want to be the best I can be an
understanding the process this this
right here has given me the roadmap so
I'm going to just thank you let me tell
you I'm a great admirer of you because
you got what it takes
thanks really thanks not I'm not been
firing for you for your success yeah I'm
admiring you for the type of person you
are and so for me the ability to pass
along things that are helpful and know
that you're also gonna pass along the
things that are helpful to you yeah it's
joy thank you for the joy and I cannot
let you leave without giving me an
autographed copy okay okay we don't can
we get a round of applause for Ray Dalio
[Music]
you